das ist wohl das dramatische ereignis
des kosmos zwei galaxienhaufen die
kollidieren bei dieser karambolage
entsteht eine region aus 100 millionen
grad heißem gas die schockwellen die
dabei entstehen gelten als die
wichtigsten teilchenbeschleuniger im
kosmos eine kollision der absoluten
superlative und ein astronomie team aus
japan hat einen solchen zusammenstoß der
giganten jetzt tatsächlich live
beobachtet klick zum zweiten fiction
gibt es täglich faszinierendes 1 videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
mitte juli erst ist das deutsche
röntgenteleskop user ins all gestartet
um endlich der mysteriösen dunklen
energie auf die schliche zu kommen im
visier des röntgen survey telescope
airways stehen unter anderem bis zu
100.000 galaxienhaufen die genauer
analysiert werden sollen
durch deren verteilung wollen
forschungsteams weltweit endlich
herausfinden wie sich das universum
ausdehnt wie es damals aussah und
natürlich auch wie es heute aussieht wir
hatten ja darüber ausführlich bei pixum
science fiction berichtet bei
galaxienhaufen handelt es sich um
ansammlungen von tausenden einzeln
galaxien die durch die schwerkraft die
gravitation miteinander verbunden sind
galaxienhaufen sind nicht nur die
größten strukturen des kosmos sondern
können auch eine masse von mehreren
milliarden sonnenmassen erreichenden
fachleute gehen davon aus dass diese
giganten durch kollisionen von galaxien
und galaxienhaufen im laufe mehrerer
milliarden jahre entstehen doch bislang
ist es noch nie gelungen die
anfangsphase einer solchen kollision
direkt zu beobachten
forschungsziel weltweit stützen sich in
diesem zusammenhang auf theoretische
modelle und auf die beobachtung von
galaxienhaufen die bereits kollidiert
sind dabei sind diese karambolagen die
wohl dramatischen ereignisse des kosmos
überhaupt dazu
der japanische astronomie kollisionen
zwischen galaxien hoffen sind die
energiereichsten ereignisse im universum
seit dem urknall
die schockwellen die bei einer solchen
verschmelzung entstehen sind
wahrscheinlich die wichtigsten
teilchenbeschleuniger im
cosmos sie setzten enorme mengen an
hitze strahlung und energiereichen
kosmischen teilchen frei es handelt sich
um änderungen kosmische energie
schleudern und so ist die aktuelle
entdeckung eines japanischen
forschungsteams eine wirklich
sensationelle premiere denn den
fachleuten gelang es erstmalig zwei
galaxienhaufen aufzuspüren die sich in
der entscheidenden phase der kollision
befinden nämlich in der sogenannten prix
merger phase
damit sind die rund 100 millionen jahre
des ersten kontakts gemeint in
astronomischen dimensionen einem
wirklich kurzer zeit dabei stoßen die
äußeren bereiche zusammen und erst dann
verschmelzen die zentren es passiert
also jetzt und wir sind live dabei
konkret handelt es sich um die beiden
galaxien hoffen mit der bezeichnung 12
15 und 16 die rund eine milliarde
lichtjahre von uns entfernt sind nach
berechnungen der experten und
expertinnen bewegen sie sich wohl schon
seit milliarden jahren aufeinander zu
allerdings in einem sehr gemächlichen
tempo mehrere röntgenteleskop
ermöglichen jetzt die erkenntnis dass
ihre kollision gerade erst begonnen hat
unter anderem zeigten beobachtungen mit
dem nasa röntgenteleskop chandra dass
die randbereiche der beiden
galaxienhaufen bereits aufeinander
gestoßen sind die zentren dagegen liegen
noch rund zwei millionen lichtjahre
auseinander dazu die elac astra einer
der beteiligten forscher
wir haben unheimliches glück dass wir
zeugen dieses ersten kontakt zwischen
den beiden clustern werden und diese
carambolage bleibt natürlich nicht ohne
folgen
es entsteht eine gewaltige schockwelle
aus heißem gas das bis zu 100 millionen
grad heiß wird dazu heißt es in der
studie
diese schock von strömt von der mitte
der kollision zone entlang der
äquatorialen ebene nach außen
diese beobachtung stimmt mit den
theoretischen modellen über ein
sie sagen voraus dass die ersten
schockwellen noch vor der kollision der
cluster gerne auftreten
die schockwelle setzt enorme energie
frei und das obwohl die kollision noch
ganz am anfang steht dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam die entdeckung enthüllt
eine wichtige epoche bei der bildung
massereicher pflaster denn die dabei
erzeugten schockwellen transportieren
einen erheblichen anteil der kinetischen
nr
die über die cluster ganzen hinaus
dadurch wird dann das intergalaktische
medium aufgeheizt und verändert die nun
aufgespürte carambolage der superlative
liefert also wichtige erkenntnisse für
die astronomie langfristig gesehen
setzen die fachleute große hoffnung auf
neue röntgenteleskop deren instrumente
weitaus sensitiver sind als die
derzeitigen neben ios etr könnte auch
der röntgensatellit ekström der in zwei
jahren 2021 ins all starten soll
spannende einblicke gewähren 2031 soll
dann das röntgen observatorium athena
folgen und dessen instrumente sind sogar
100 mal sensitiver als die von shunra
wir werden also mit diesen satelliten
und sondern noch eine menge entdeckungen
machen zum beispiel über den exoplaneten
proxima centauri neue studie zeigt
außerirdisches leben könnte ganz nahe
sein dieses video anklicken anschauen
und dann dem megacoolen kanal neugier
zone unbedingt abonnieren sie empfehlen
auch 2008 bis 10.000 und ich würde ihnen
gerne mit ganz vielen abos unterstützen
also unterstützt markus von neugier zone
bitte mit einem abo bis dann bleibt dran